with reaction Fox News contributor
former Speaker of the House new gingr
all right first your general thoughts
what did you think and you know why why
is this is their Mass migration out of
New York Illinois New Jersey California
but they're moving to Florida Texas
Tennessee the
Carolinas
why well I mean first of all um clist
and I watched last night with great
interest I've known you a long time you
were the big winner last night uh you
did a great job you were very fact-based
I love the way you'd put up charts that
were just factual uh you were balanced
uh and you stayed in control and really
I think uh it it may be as good a
performance as you've had in your entire
career and that's set the stage I think
on on substance danis clearly won but
that's because danis has a heck of a lot
better case and I thought Gavin who I've
known Gavin since he was mayor of San
Francisco wrote a very smart book on on
modern technology and citizenship and
Gavin is very clever but if you watched
him last night there were two things
going on praising uh Joe Biden to prove
to the Democratic party he's loyal and
personally attacking uh Governor Dan
sanis because he couldn't answer the
questions I I thought the most obvious
was when you said I thought it was a
great question you said to each of them
tell me something you like about the
other state does sis
was prepared had lived there like
California frankly his answer could be a
commercial for California Nome could not
say a single word about Florida even
though his in-laws live in Florida uh
and I just thought it was an interesting
contrast you know Nome had to go on the
attack and be personal rather than deal
with the issues yeah you know I go back
and we've go back a long time I was the
MC the night you became speaker and that
was for me like a dream come true and we
been really good friends Almost Family
for ever since and um you've been a a
mentor in so many ways to me and one of
the things that I wanted to do is I
really we where I spent the most time I
wanted to focus on two things one what
are the issues that impact everybody and
and that would be taxes that would be
immigration that would be energy that
would be gas prices Etc crime and then
the second thing was I had to get my
facts lined up fact check everything cuz
I knew the media would want to you know
attack me if I got one thing wrong and
you know me and my great staff we we
really did a lot of due diligence to get
it right um and I thought it was
worthwhile for the country to hear from
both sides and I think it's beneficial
it was it was really a model yeah let me
let me just say I thought it was a model
because when you would put up a chart it
was all fact-based it was it wasn't
slanted it wasn't right or left this
this wasn't Hannity the commentator who
can be pretty aggressive this was a guy
trying to give two significant Governors
the largest and third largest states in
the country a chance to explain why
they're different and of course the
great problem for Gavin Nome is uh when
you get down to the facts it's a fact
people are fleeing California now he
doesn't want to talk about that so then
attacks Nome it's a fact that gasoline's
about $2 50 a gallon higher in
California he doesn't want to talk about
that it's a fact as you pointed out uh
and where I thought I thought probably
Nome was the least in touch with reality
if you have a zero income tax in Florida
and a 7% income tax in California how
can you argue that Floridians pay higher
taxes than people in California it it
was just a fascinating moment but all of
it what I admired was two things all of
it was fact-based you were putting up
charts you could see where the facts
came from and second when it got
contentious you didn't get sucked in you
didn't become the third debator you you
were more mature and more a real
moderator than almost anybody I've seen
in the so-called presidential debates
wow that coming from you that's a high
compliment um I do think the years that
I have moderated debates on radio
certainly help but Mr Speaker uh we
appreciate you being with us thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else